Wow! The site turned out really beautiful.
Just look at this seamless experience.
As I scroll, the scenes change,
and along with the scenes the text
changes too. So there's a story on the
site. I'm really excited that I built
this story, and just as excited to tell you about
it. This scroll experience is amazing, I think.
So today we're not just going to build a
website and move on. Thanks to these four
Claude skills, you'll be able to build scroll-triggered
websites like the one you see on screen right now,
websites that look really aesthetic,
in your own projects. And the
best part is this: it's being explained by
someone who's actually in the trenches.
Since I work as a developer, I also
build projects for my own clients
using these skills. So I'm
telling you about skills
I've actually experienced. This way, your
context in Claude doesn't fill up, and
you learn skills that will genuinely be useful
to you. Now, where did I get the inspiration
for this website? I want to
show you that right away.
As you know, I love Awwwards.
Studying award-winning websites
is one of my hobbies. Because it
trains my design eye, and that's
how I'm able to build dynamic
websites, and I recommend it
to you too. Now, this website was published
on August 14. It hasn't won an award
yet, but I think it most likely will.
Because first there's a voting phase. So
you usually don't win an award
quickly. There's a vote. Then you
win the award. Step by step, I'll
explain all that in another video. Now
I want to show you the website, and
it really has a beautiful flow. Look,
first we're greeted by a woman wiping
a pear with her hand. But as I refresh
the page, the scene keeps changing.
Let's refresh a few more times.
Look, now it's a woman holding a
pear. They made three different scenes
for the intro. Sometimes a curtain is drawn,
sometimes she's holding a pear, and sometimes
she's wiping the pear. That's creative
too. Now when I scroll, the story
begins. Look, first someone ties
something to a tree. Then a pear falls.
Someone catches the pear, cuts it, and
then a different scene. Look, it's still
telling something here. So they've
built a structure that keeps the user
scrolling constantly. That's the
truly creative part. I mean, everyone
can use AI well. The most important thing
here is skill. The better your skills, the
better websites you can build. So
it's perfect. Look, this is the form.
By the way, they made the forms with stars
like this too. So the form is really creative.
And here's the final section, the footer
section. Now when I go back, the same flow
continues, just like on ours. As soon as
I saw this website, I said I absolutely
have to build this. So I thought about
how they did it. I thought about
the skills. The skills in Claude. So
I'm not going to build this with long
prompts in this video. I actually created
a video too, and I wanted to use
a slightly more vivid blue. It's
called Saxony blue. Now when I
scroll, look, it goes inside.
She's holding fabric. She hands the fabric
to someone else and the text appears. Look,
after that, if you noticed over here,
by the way, there's a navigation
that shows where you are on the page.
I built that too. So as you scroll,
that changes as well. And I take
the pear. Someone holds the pear and
it bursts in their hand.
I really loved that scene.
After that, a ball appears
where everyone is, and
it goes back to the very first section.
Then the slider section with information
about the page, which we can scroll, and
the footer. And in the footer, this part
turned out really creative. Look, when I
move the mouse over it, light appears. This
turned out pretty creative, and honestly
I didn't do this. I didn't say it
in the prompt. Claude came up with it.
Thanks to these skills, you don't need to
add tons of skills. A maximum
of 10 skills lets you build
websites like this. But of course the idea
is the most important thing here. Because
everyone uses AI well, but talented
people are very few, and this
comes from talent. So now let me
show you the GitHub repos. Now I'll
tell you a bit about the four skills.
I say "a bit" because we'll be
using them actively anyway. So the goal
here isn't to explain the skills at length.
Everyone explains skills now,
but I'm going to show you
how to actually use them. Now, we'll see why
these four skills are valuable as I explain
and as we experience them. Our first skill
is the Anthropic Skills skill. By the way,
other YouTubers have probably already
shown you this one, because it's very
common. But the other skills I'll
show you are different. Skills that
other YouTubers most likely don't
know about. Because I research them
as a developer, that's why I'm telling you,
and I actively use them. Now let's look at
this skill first. First,
Anthropic's frontend-design skill
helps Claude break out of the
classic generic AI landing page look.
So what does that mean? You know those
websites AI makes with the classic
neon colors? This skill was released to
stop it from making those, to stop it from
producing template-style websites,
to reduce that. So "don't do
those parts. Use these fonts,
these buttons, these colors,"
that's the kind of skill they've released.
And thanks to this, it doesn't look like
AI-made websites. And the other
skill I love is the T skill. I really
love this skill. Because it helps you
control how experimental, how animated and
how dense the design will be.
So what does that mean? Well,
think of it this way. When a classic website
is built, of course it has to continue
in a classic way. There's a theme there.
You have to stay consistent with that theme.
But if we have a dynamic website
like this, we shouldn't continue it
in a classic way. Because the theme there
is animated. So this is a skill that
thinks about that. Look, it's incredibly good.
I definitely recommend installing this skill,
which determines whether your website
behaves in an animated or a classic
way. This way, say you've started
a project halfway, and that project
is animated and needs to continue being
animated. This skill detects that,
reads it, and continues that way. That's
incredibly valuable. So the skill actually
helps you by picking up a bit
on your own behavior. This way,
in your freelance work, when you take on jobs
from clients and continue a half-finished
project, this skill helps you a
lot. And the Scroll Craft skill,
that one's tremendous too. Why? Because the
website I showed you a moment ago was actually
built actively with Scroll Craft. You know
how text comes in from the right and left
as you scroll, that scroll
behavior? That's done
with this skill. It's an active skill you'll
use especially on award-winning websites
like the ones on Awwwards. I mean it for
websites that won awards on Awwwards. These are
the skills you keep asking me
about. I use around 9 or 10 skills
on average, and I'll show you these
skills in two, even three different
videos. Because if I show them in a single
video, you won't really learn them,
you'll memorize them, but I prefer
to move forward by trying things and
teaching you this way. Now let's
get to our last skill and then
build the project with Claude. They
say the best is always saved for last,
so that's why I wanted to save it
for last in this video. Design DNA
is a really good skill. Why do I say
that? Because you ask me about this a lot
in the comments. Say you liked a
website and all you have is an image
or a video. You want to send that
image or video to an AI and have it
analyze it. That's exactly what this
skill does. When you send an image
or a video, it first analyzes the
website, and from that analysis,
the font, the spacing, the
visuals, the text, basically every
part of the website you can think of, it analyzes
and thinks it through and builds the website
with you. So it doesn't make a copy. Look, it
analyzes with you and, taking inspiration,
it can build a different website, or it
can build the same one. That entirely
depends on your prompt. But the most important
thing is that it analyzes. I emphasize this
in all my videos, and that it builds the
project by thinking from scratch. That's exactly
what this skill does, and
actually a lot of people use this
in projects, but YouTubers usually
recommend the basic skills, and all
websites started to look alike.
That's why I wanted to step in
and tell you about these skills.
Now you can download these four
skills to your computer
and use them actively
in your projects, and they'll be really
useful to you. I think you'll be
thanking me. In the next video, I'll
cover different skills too. They'll also
be very useful to you. Now let's go
back to Claude and build the website
from scratch. Before sending the prompt,
I want to show it to you on screen
now. You can see it in both Turkish
and English. And I'll leave it
below. You can build
scroll-triggered websites too. But
remember, you need to have a
video. So create a video like
this. You can actually create it with
any AI tool. I used Seedance 2.5.
For scroll-triggered websites like this,
I recommend building them with Seedance
2.5. It's a very powerful model, and if
you're wondering how to generate it,
I actually explained it in my
previous video. You can watch that
in detail. If you noticed, in the first part
of the prompt, my first sentences say it needs
to actively use these four
skills. You don't have to
say this, because you've already installed
them as skills, but if you do, it's to your
benefit, because you're reminding
Claude. You're dealing with an
AI tool, and it works entirely
according to how you direct it.
I wanted to emphasize that. After
that, I say it should take the pe page
as an example. Look, I'm saying
it should take inspiration, not
make a copy. The design
skill here is exactly
what comes into play here. Taking inspiration
from the peer page, thinking about how
it was built, analyzing it, it will
create a project for us from scratch. And
you know me, I usually write
technically in my prompts.
I mean I put code in, but look,
I didn't put any code here.
I wanted to mention that in case some of
you know me from other videos. So here
I'm just saying "do this." Triggered by
scroll behavior, with a video that moves
as you scroll, and then text
related to the scene appearing,
and with that, I told it to create
a seamless flow. If you noticed,
the skills will really do all of
this. I wanted to show you this
in detail. Now, I'm using
Fable 5 as the model. You
can use Opus too, but the flow here is
very important. Having it move as you
scroll is a bit tricky. That's why I wanted
to use a powerful model. Opus does it
quite well too, by the
way. Now I'm sending this,
and we'll look at the result together
shortly. To help you see the project better,
I moved myself to the left. Because
when you see the part where it changed
the design in a moment, you'll be surprised. It
really made a beautiful design. It used the skills
correctly. By the way, I forgot to say
this at the beginning. This design, this
website works on all devices.
Mobile devices, tablets,
desktops and large screens. I forgot to
mention that, but it's in the prompt
anyway. Responsive, meaning I told it
to make it work on all devices, and
when it used the skills, it had
to build on that basis anyway.
It's already in the skills. Now
I'm dying to show you the result.
Now we're greeted by the same screen as the
previous website. Which is perfectly normal. We
gave it a video, and it brings in
text by moving the video. But now
you'll see in a moment where
it changed the designs. As I
scroll, we go inside the world, and
look, we see the first thing it changed
on the side. In the previous design I
had used a line on the right side, but
here it used a circle, and
using a circle makes much more
sense design-wise. Because there are circular
lines here. If you noticed. And using
a circle here actually creates
unity. And as I scroll,
look, the scenes move smoothly, and bam,
this part is really good. Why? When we
scrolled on the previous website, we were
actually still on a website with a blue
background. But using
white here doesn't strain
our eyes. Why? Because there's too much blue.
Blue and yellow. Switching straight to white
here focuses my attention, and
it's more like a minimal design
now. Even though the top is
dynamic. So I really liked this
choice in that respect, and look, the text
font, even down to the copy button there,
even the color of that copy button,
it made it connected to that. I
didn't give it that. Normally I
write these out at length in prompts,
as you know, but by adding the right skills
like this, we can build award-winning
websites like this. Of course,
I didn't create this video
from scratch. As you know, I took inspiration.
So to be able to do these things,
you need to keep improving your
skills constantly. Of course,
just using AI well doesn't produce
results like this right away. Now I'm
scrolling. Look, it's really nice that
the text here comes in too. It appears
as I scroll. That's correct, but when you
scroll down, the text disappears. It made a
mistake here, but a very simple one.
If you take a screenshot of this and
say "fix this," like "don't
let it disappear when I
scroll," it won't disappear.
So it's a very simple mistake.
Nothing that breaks the flow. I liked this
part. Why? Look, it picked very striking
visuals. I didn't give it these. By the way,
it decided on its own from inside the video
and picked the most striking, most
important scenes. That transition there,
look, her walking off holding the fabric like
that and so on, those were the most important
scenes. So it's great that it picked
those correctly, and using the full screen
is good. At the very end, this is the footer. Using the
footer full-screen like this too, along with the intro,
makes sense. It keeps a sense of unity.
That's actually important too. Also,
look, I want to show you the mobile
version. I almost forgot that just now.
Now I've switched to iPhone 14 Pro Max and
refreshed the page. By the way, you can change
the intro here. Like, you can say
"don't start from here, start a bit
closer to the woman." Here it
just started from the left side
of the video. So you can fix all
of these by prompting, but this
isn't a wrong design either. It just
chose it that way. Now I'm scrolling.
Look, it's the same again. We go inside
it. The curtain comes. Look, it even
shrank the circle here.
Look, it will still
look like this on mobile phones
too, on all devices. Look,
this part is quite good too. You could
even center this, but even this view
isn't wrong. For example, you could make
this heading bigger. You could move it
higher up, there are many things
like that. And this is the footer,
so it's mobile-friendly. You ask
me a lot in the comments: okay,
we build websites like this, but are they
compatible with all devices? Yes, I pay
a lot of attention to this in all my
projects. I try to build them to work
on all devices, so the user can use them
without any problems. I'm really happy with the result.
As soon as I saw the site, I said I have to build this
right away and tell you about it on
YouTube. Because you also love different
designs, from what I gather from
the comments. If you also see
websites like this and like them, you can
write to me in the comments. Like "Yıldız,
I saw a website like this,
how could we build it?"
I'll definitely consider it. By the
way, I'll keep going with Claude
skills. I use many other different
skills. I'll show you those
too, but I wanted to show them project
by project. Because here's the thing.
If I explained 10 skills here one after
another, they wouldn't stick in your mind. But
when we use them project by project like
this, if you've noticed, they settle in your
head better. So I try to teach
you the way I learn myself. That's
why I show you step by step. I don't
cover it in a single video. Now
in the next videos I'll cover
the other skills I use, and
I'll do it in a different
project. Thank you so much
for watching. I'm really curious about
your comments, and as you know, you can
comment in whatever language you
like. I actively reply to comments.
What I mean by "you can comment in
whatever language you like" is this: our
videos are actually watched not just in
Turkey but in many different countries,
and from what I see in YouTube Analytics,
we've reached more than 50 countries, and
I'm really happy about that. If you're not
subscribed to the channel, don't forget
to subscribe. I'd be very happy to see
you among us. If you're not subscribed
to the channel, don't forget to subscribe, and
if you liked the video, don't forget to hit
the like button. Thank
you again for listening.
See you in the next videos. Goodbye.